hello everyone and welcome to round five
of the 2021 norway chess yes it's the
round where we will finally show the
standings of the tournament uh but here
we have an armageddon game between uh
yanni ponchi and rihardport and it's
quite a beauty so let's dive straight
into it and then we're going to discuss
the standings and well who who's done
well so far uh nipple with the white
pieces opens with e4 and already action
from the from the first move we have d5
rapport goes for the scandinavian
defense uh with e captures on the e5
queen captures and the knights the c3
taking advantage of the queen being
developed early and now queen to a5 if
you guys are interested um maybe in some
scandinavian uh secrets and knowledge i
made a short tutorial on queen to d6
line here uh if you guys want to check
it out it will be in the description
below the first link it's uh it's quite
a nice nice line uh we have queen to a5
and now d4 this is i believe still
considered the main line we have d4
and now knight to f6 we have knight to
f3 and bishop to f5 now nicely
developing here and now knight to e5 a
standard move
against the scandinavian especially when
the queen is on a5 the queen will always
have to look out for this knight to c4
move and then the two knights around the
black queen could get very uncomfortable
so here we have c6 another standard
scandinavian move you want to make room
for the queen to be able to retreat to
c7 or d8 and now bishop to f4 developing
a piece while also kind of x-raying that
c7 square maybe queen to c7 will not be
the greatest of retreats so e6 now
and here we have g4 this is all very
well known bishop g6 we have h4 uh
preparing h5 and now bishop to b4
attacking the
pinned piece once again uh and you don't
really have a problem with h5 you're
just going to play bishop to e4 the
knight here cannot move and then you're
going to shift the bishop to d5 this is
the standard plan so bishop d2 adding
another defender to the c3 square here
and now there is a game where queen to
b6 was played but here we have knight b
to d7 by rapport and it is now as of
move 10 that we have a completely new
game uh so what do you do here well you
start with knight captures on d7 uh
definitely makes sense because black has
to capture with the king if you capture
with the knight h5 traps the bishop now
you don't have this knight bishop to e4
line as uh the bishop is on d2 the
knight can freely capture the bishop so
instead we have king captures on d7 now
the king is still in the center of the
board but a few moves and you will
castle the safety shouldn't be a prop a
problem uh we have h5 nonetheless bishop
to e4 attacking nepal's rook here
uh and rook to h3 we have h6 uh in the
now a3 asking black what do you want to
do here with this bishop and you have to
capture on c3 if you don't uh well it's
going to be a problem we're just if for
example you move the bishop we just
capture this bishop and open up a
discovery against the black queen and we
win the game so bishop captures only
move we have not bishop captures but
rook captures now threatening some
discoveries and finally queen back to c7
uh we have queen to e2 uh preparing
maybe the castle queen side also you
want to gain control of the e4 square
maybe with the future moves like e3 and
f3 to really control this knight here so
it doesn't have any useful squares uh
bishop back to d5 and now rook to e3
also c4 is definitely an idea so b5
preventing this and now b3 so we have to
further prepare our c4 move and now it's
very hard for a rapper to even make a
move here as you can see there really
aren't all that many active moves you
can't really do all that much much with
the bishop with the knight you could
start maybe with
some rook moves maybe bringing the rook
to lines that might open up in the
future but rapper prepares a very
devious plan he plays queen to h2 as
he's a pretty uh interesting player
himself so of course he wants to always
make things interesting which is not
always easy when you have to play
armageddon with black or
just uh just a draw is enough for you to
win the game but that's not the kind of
player he is and now nepo has to decide
whether he wants to play some like f3
and really take care of this knight or
for a queen trade and now let's say if
queen g3 check we can even block and now
let's say we trade here and it will
always be white who's better here
because black's pieces just don't have
all that much to do
black can merely wait and see what what
white uh goes for so instead we have
rook to g3 uh by nepo and now knight to
e4 so what is rapport's plan here we
have rook to h3 now only now attacking
the queen and now you could go back
queen to c7 then we would see something
like c4 captures captures the bishop now
has to move but you don't really have a
square so we're going to capture on d2
queen captures bishop to e4 and the game
continues with white being better
but it's still completely crazy however
uh rapport is not that kind of a player
he instead played knight captures on d2
he offers his queen uh for a minor piece
and the rook so let's see how nipple
continues he of course captures the
queen there is nothing better
we have rook captures on h2 and now
knight to f3 check a nice fork that will
grab the rook on h2 king to d1 knight
captures an h2 and here uh
uh he has nipple now has a queen for a
rook and minor piece and well how do how
how will you how will you play this
first you have to activate this rook and
then you have to find something useful
for this bishop but king the c1 of
course you want to play king to b2 and
then maybe get the rook into the game or
maybe you're going to play a4 and try to
get the open a file for the rook so
knight captures an f1 rapper says this
bishop might even become a useful piece
so i'm going to trade it we have queen
captures and now a5
we have queen to eat you by nipple and
now even b4 he says that opening uh
of the a file and trading a pair of
rooks that will favor black so it
captures on b four a captures and now we
have uh sorry wrong rook rook capture
sun a8 rook capture 78 and now king the
b2 not allowing any infiltrating moves
here and now we have a queen against the
rook and bishop so can a rapport hold
this to a draw or maybe even win the
game uh let's see he starts with f6
grabs more more
space here controlling a lot of squares
and it's a question how will nipple
break through well he starts with f4 of
course you want to uh eliminate as many
pawns as possible and then try to
make some threats against the the black
king while also maybe connecting the
attacks with the bishop or the rook so
here rook to a5 and now comes queen to
d3 trying to infiltrate the position
maybe go after that pawn so rapper uh
hurries back with the king we have queen
to h7 and now king to fade the defending
we have queen h8 to check king to f7 and
now queen to d8 this is how uh niepo
infiltrates with an attack on the rook
so rook to b5 uh and now g5 this is what
we were going for all along f captures
we have f captures h captures and queen
captures and g5 so now the queen can
move around a bit more freely and uh
well hopefully we can we can do some
damage here but it's still not all that
clear how uh the bishop and pawns are
covering each other basically and well
good luck taking care of this rook so
it's not going to be easy uh here uh you
could try maybe rook bishop captures on
b3 to open up a discovery here but just
a simple check and you just wasted your
bishop away king of f8 we're gonna
capture on b3 if any of you were
wondering why not just bishop captures
on b3 and i know some of you were
wondering that so here rook the b7 was
played why not just keep an eye on the
seventh rank and now queen back to d8 so
what can hippo do here well he wants to
somehow harass this rook maybe push him
away from the b file and go after the b
pawn it's on a dark square black has a
light square bishop so you can't really
defend it this way only the rook can
defend it so that's the the plan here so
rook the b5 and the queen to d7 check
king f8 now comes king to c1 now we have
to start bringing our king into the game
to help out with uh well maybe even a
mating attack so king g8 now comes king
d2 we have uh king to h7 now comes queen
to f7 we have king the h8 and now king
to e3 we have rooked the b8 now
and the queen to e7 so here uh you have
to be very careful it's uh it's a very
tricky position because if you place
them like king to h7 then white can even
win the game with h6 this would be uh
very cool problem is uh if the king
captures because the g pawn is pinned
you have this queen h4 check king g6 and
now queen g3 check winning the rook on
b8 so you always have to keep an eye on
that so after king to g8 we have queen
to d6 now putting pressure on the rook
also maybe trying to get the rook away
from the b file so rook b7 queen to d8
to check king to h7 and now queen to e8
so again maybe some queen g6 h6 ideas
but it never really works as long as the
king is on h8
so rook to a7 and now queen to g6 check
king to h8 queen eight check we have
king back to h7 and now queen to b8
again attacking the rook and the pawn
here and now you can't really keep an
eye on this pawn so rook to a2 going
after the c2 pawn but now king d3 yeah
simply defending it uh we have bishop to
f3 going after the h5 pawn and now queen
captures on b4 uh we have bishop
captures on h5 so one of the threats has
been eliminated but now these pawns are
incredibly strong so here we have c4
and the bishop the g6 check now we have
kink to e3 now you don't want to play a
move like king c3 because then rook to
c2 is checkmate in one that would be
pretty bad so of course king to e3 and
now rook to b2 uh we have queen to a3
pushing the rook back rook to b1 now
queen to a4 going after the c6 spawn as
well uh bishop to f5 now robert will of
course try pushing his jeep on uh and
the king to f4 uh stopping pawn to g5 so
king h6 and now queen captures in c6 but
now rapport also gets to push his past
pawn so g5 check king to e5 and now king
to h5 now we have d5 that that pawn is
uh now becoming a pass pawn uh rook to
e1 with check king f6 and now rook to f1
so threatening some very nasty
discoveries here uh so we have to move
the king king g7 and now e captures on
d5 we have c captures on d5 and now rook
to d1 the rook and bishop nicely
controlling d7
but
it will do a little good because nipple
also has a b pawn so pawn to b4 yes
always that pawn to b4 signalizes a
great uh well victory uh we have king to
g4 and now b5 we have bishop to e for
pinning this pawn but doesn't matter
queen to e6 check king to f4 now d6
preparing d7 so bishop to f5 controlling
the d7 square but just queen to e2 we
attacked the rook and now uh what do you
play here the problem is you could
capture this pawn uh better than just
queen to h2 check and you lose the rook
so unfortunately you can't play that
rook to d5 was played and here we have
b6 and now again the idea is the same
you can't capture this because of queen
h2 check you lose the rook so g4 was
played but here just b7 and it was in
this position on move 69
that
rihard rapport resigned the game as
there is nothing more to be done here so
again rapport uh plays uh impeccable in
the classical game but uh he he falters
a little bit in the armageddon but so
far he and nipple are the only two
players to not have lost a classical
game which is incredible uh as
well the competition here is just
incredibly fair so here we resign uh
there's well no hope against b8 there's
no way to defend this the queen covers
b5 so there's no rook to b5 and this
pawn is much too far away to do anything
to you know
in the
ways of getting promoted so here the
only sensible thing was to resign and
that is what rapport did so before i
forget here are the standings after five
rounds we are at the half mark of the
tournament uh let's check it out so
leading the tournament rehard rapport
with nine and a half uh
uh points followed by ani pomnishi with
eight and a half sergey karjakin with
seven out of uh well out of something uh
magnus carlsen in fourth place already
in fifth and arientari in sixth place so
these are the current standings but uh
now the we still have uh
basically 50 of the tournament to cover
and who knows what might happen but if
rapport can continue this uh well like i
said he could emerge as world number
five after this tournament is over if he
gets like like two more two more
victories in classical you know it's
very unlikely for anyone to get two
victories in classical but he already
got two so you never know he plays uh
very interesting chess you know might
might you know good things might happen
uh so yeah that's the game i hope you
guys enjoyed it uh very very fierce
summer getting game i would like to
thank matthew coleman the b file tom
deralo happy birthday heather rose and
tom kitching for your contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
all my previous videos here thank you
for watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of this very
nice tournament checking up on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the chess world
thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day